Let me show you something with my car.
You know how sometimes you walk up to the trunk
and your hands are full, well here's how you do it.
>> That's really cool.
>> want to try?
>> Can I try? [SOUND]
>> So
were you kicking something?
>> How do you think it works?
>> Is there a particular place?
>> Mm. So what do you think is going on?
>> Oh, oh, there it goes.
>> So what did you do?
>> I'm not sure what I did.
>> You think you could do it again?
>> Well, I don't know. Let's see.
>> Yeah. So what's-
>> I don't know what I did.
>> So what's your conceptual model of what's going on?
>> [LAUGH] Maybe there's a sensor there, and I have to,
>> Somewhere.
>> Yeah, somewhere under there. It looks like.
>> You know,
this is a really good example, if you like,
it's a good example of a bad example of crossing
the gulf of execution and the gulf of evaluation.
The gulf of execution. Well I'm suppose to kick or
something, but where and how? How fast, or do
I kick or just wave my foot? And the gulf
of execution, well I did it and nothing happened.
Now what am I suppose to do? Really good example
of bad design.